797, 798, 799.
I have counted these towels
13 times,
and each time
the number is 799.
Bellacourt Manor
is an 800-towel estate.
Whomever stole the towel,
please step forward.
You'll be fired immediately,
no questions asked.
- Garfield.
- Hmm?
Garfield,
empty your breast.
Is that a towel I see?
Who?
This is Towel?
Chair gave her to me.
And she kissed me.
[all snickering]
Enough!
It is stolen property!
Garfield Leopold McGillicutty,
you are hereby stripped of all
duties befitting an underbutler.
Please remove your uniform
and vacate the premises
immediately.
You may pick up the clothes
you wore when you arrived.
But when I came here,
I was six years old.
Yes, back
when I saw something in you,
something
that reminded me of...
Servants, turn away.
Nicholas, bang the pot.
[metal clanks]
Dead man walking.
Slower, Nick, slower.
[metal clanks]
[zipper opens]
Go, boy.
Go and find your way
in this wicked world.
[Garfield crying]